dr karl weiss est avec nous dr weiss
bonsoir vous avez donc vu ces dates
depuis hier dont les écoles d'abord hier
aujourd'hui les commerces les
manufactures les industries les la
construction qui vont tous se repartir
au mois de mai premier commentaire bon
monsieur le docteur arruda distincts
risque mais un risque calculé
êtes vous d'accord avec la proche quels
sont vos premiers commentaires sur la
séquence
oui c'est un risque mais un risque
calculé c'est clair que on peut pas
avoir toutes les garanties mais vous
savez le confinement lui même était un
risque est un risque calculé
ça prend du courage d'arrêter toute une
société dans la société dans laquelle on
vit
donc il a fallu arrêter toute la société
c'était un gros risque en espérant que
ça allait fonctionner donc on fera tout
le temps des risques maintenant on va
prendre un risque inverse celui qui est
un déconfinement graduelle parce que les
c'est aussi toute la société un
confinement et un autre risque un risque
d'avoir d'autres problèmes des problèmes
sociaux on le voit des problèmes mentaux
dans l'ordre un certaine partie de la
population
il y avait la santé mentale des
individus qui joue un rôle aussi
important et des problèmes économiques
des impacts économiques sur la santé
physique la santé mentale
donc il ya un ensemble de facteurs et je
pense qu'il faut aller au delà de le
simplement dire est ce que c'est une
partie de la population qui va être
immunisé ou pas c'est pas le sépare du
débat le débat c'est quels sont les
avantages de des confiné lentement par
rapport à ne rien faire et de votre
point de vue dans un hôpital qui reçoit
des cas de co 20 19
vous jugez que c'est un risque est
acceptable de prendre actuellement
écoutez on a une certaine profondeur une
certaine réserve au niveau du système
hospitalier gu mais cette réserve là va
aussi fausse parce qu'il va falloir
reprendre des activités normales on peut
pas continuer indéfiniment à ne pas
traiter des cancers ne pas faire de
chirurgie on peut pas faire ce qu'on
peut pas arrêter de façon continue ce
qu'on est en train de faire actuellement
donc il ya aussi un travail de ce côté
là en faire c'est un risque qui va être
quelque
les et on va voir comment l
épidémiologie va arriver faut dire qu'on
a on a absorbé la première 20 la
première vague a été la plus difficile
parce qu'on était pas préparé au québec
y avait pas une préparation qui était je
vous dirai à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
pouvaient frapper en termes ans et
d'équipement de masse une là on est on
commence à être un peu mieux préparé on
a des tests il va falloir encore nous
améliorer
donc on a des outils qu'on avait pas il
ya dix ans deux mois et on va avoir de
meilleurs outils dans encore dans deux
mois alors tout ça mis ensemble ça va
être un risque calculé ça va être un
exercice de jongler c'est un exercice de
jongleurs où on va essayer de
tranquillement m goutte à goutte
le système marche peut-être un filet
d'eau puis après ça peut être un robinet
plus ouvert et ainsi de suite en
envoyant les conséquences et à quelle
maman justement vous allez dire comme
professionnels comme médecin que les
conséquences sont trop lourdes et que
faudra peut-être reculer est ce qu'il ya
quel sera votre mesure pour faire ça
m'affecter ce médecin ça va être le
suivi du nombre de cas le nom de vincent
qui va être hospitalisé le nom de
patients qui va arriver aux soins
intensifs un peu le nom de décès ont
surtout et une fois qu'on aura le même
suivi au point de vue épidémiologique on
a actuellement on va avoir une idée de
ce qui se passe il faut savoir qu'il
faudrait augmenter nos capacités de
tester parce que si des enfants tombent
malades faudrait également les tester
tester peut-être les gens autour d'eux
on va avoir des capacités de sérologie
dans les mois qui vont venir
donc on ça va être un très bon test et
il ya un test de préparation aussi pour
les vagues successives qui va arriver
certainement à l'automne et et par la
suite d'accord donc en terminale dr
weiss vous dites c'est possible qu'on
doive reculé on le souhaite pas mais
c'est possible il faut il faut il faut
se dire ça aussi regardez c'est comme
une bataille
l'objectif ça pouvait être vous gagner
la bataille si à un moment donné il faut
laisser un peu de terrain l'adversaire
et puis le reprendre par la suite
alors il faudra faire ce genre de choses
là donc il faut être très adaptable et à
s'adapter à la situation continuellement
ya personne qui a fait ça dans
l'histoire où on part de surtout
l'histoire moderne
confinement déconfinement avec les
risques que ça peut encourir donc tout
le monde est un tout le monde est en
train d'apprendre on n'est pas le seul
endroit dans le monde
il ya d'autres pays qui le font alors il
faut s'adapter si quelque chose va oui
on ferme le robinet on s'ajuste qu'un
vase toujours est clair merci beaucoup
merci président ou au si on va au revoir
alors l'autre aspect de la question
c'est l'aspect économique clément gignac
est avec nous je gignac comment allez
vous d'un point de vue d'un économiste
qu'est ce que ce qu'ont annoncé
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire c'est un bon rythme
comment vous voyez les choses
oui je te précise patrice parce que on
voit clairement que le ministre fait de
voir il semble s'être inspiré des
meilleures presse et qu'on observait une
main dans les pays en asie il y en aura
donc encore d'une reprise graduelle et
même page région par secteur par phases
équipe vraiment être vers cincom
expliqué dr va s et mais aussi avec la
préoccupation au niveau sanitaire parce
qu'il ya un exercice de pédagogie que le
minispace ville doit faire et tout les
employeurs du québec ne devront le faire
est-ce que leurs travailleurs quelles
sont les conditions d'une paix comme en
mettant en place pour que votre vie ne
soit en danger ou du moins que vous
ramenez pas levé 2,9 à la maison
précaution et toutes les mesures
sanitaires et le fait que la cnss st lô
dévoiler où ce point de voile et le
guide esprit aux envoyeurs ça sera quoi
les mesures on voit qu'ils étaient
planifiés réfléchissent être avant cela
et pour que ça fonctionne il faut aussi
qu'elle est au bout de la ligne des
clients faut que des gens soient dans
les commerces qui sait rendre soit des
commandes pour les mêmes facture donc il
faut que la ruhr parts à tous les points
de vue oui c'est sur faut bien penser le
que cela bosley d'une reprise en v
sawaris le 100e du nouveau d'économies
comme ce qui est de faire baisser la
première fois le confirme une économie
puis là on ferme tout les moteurs font
plaisir
le voir partir donc on y va
graduellement donc le support aux
travailleurs ou le support des
prestations canadiennes d'urgence pour
ceux qui ne récupère pas leur emploi
suite ce ça continue donc voir une
concertation fédérale provinciale mais
ça va prendre un certain temps et ben
connaît une reprise est racée et marquer
quand même à compter du 3ème 4ème
trimestre cette reprise lente mais
carmen avant qu'on retrouve patrice le
niveau d'activité économique de l'an
dernier ça on va parler de quelques
années il a eu non pas quelques mots
quelques trimestres va prendre un
certain temps
pourquoi pour unir main vous retrouver
deux bassins deuxièmement des ménages
ont tendance est plus prudent sur un
gars dans l'histoire yeux des jeux 2d
pandémie est là les ménages sont plus
prudents les entreprises également mais
y aura une reprise quand même important
de l'économie mais il se pourrait que
malheureusement ce soit pas tout le
monde trouve ça manque le coup sur
l'emploi justement le coût économique de
cette crise énorme
comment vous le mesurer vous au cours de
la prochaine année de l'autre année
d'après midi le point le super on a des
raisons sanitaires ont de fait cela il
faudrait que le randonneur el pais au
niveau des travailleurs supporter
travailleurs les entreprises dont on
parle de l'augmentation des recettes
budgétaires
oui c'est une augmentation très
significative par contre les taux
d'intérêt sont pratiquement prêts 2 0 et
si le coup c'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour éviter une dépression économique
comme dans les intrants ou que tout les
licenciements temporaires devient des
licenciements permanents
donc on ne peut pas jouer ça va prendre
un certain temps mais le fait qu'on
regard des taux d'intérêt très très
faible
le fait que beaucoup de mesures qui ont
été annoncées patrie sont de nature
temporaire en sorte que quand même une
réduction à 6 après c'est rejeter ce
budget permet qu'on voit des budgets qui
débris acquis bien côté wallon ça va
prendre pas mal d'années mac os x ce
serait parce que je lui recommanderais
non plus de faire de balancer de budget
dans les toits que d'un point de vue d
des gens des travailleurs des gens qui
vont perdre qui ont déjà perdu leur
emploi qui maintenant ont des
prestations d'urgence v70 pahlavi les
prestations d'urgence va avant que le
taux de chômage ressemble à celui qu'on
avait avant ça va prendre du temps c'est
ce que vous dites quand même oui c'est
sûr malheureusement c'est ce précepte 1
2 3 4 1 avant de revenir autour de 20
points qu'on avait l'an passé c'était un
supplément pour les plus élevés jamais
vue en 30 ans donc un certain temps
pourquoi parce que les ménages ont
tendance est plus prudent quand on
arrive sur des jaunes à demain fait mais
pour la majorité des gens qui nous
regardent ce soir ils vont retrouver
leur emploi mais il se pourrait que ça
je prenne un peu plus de temps dans
certains secteurs
surtout le côté touristes tant qu'on est
pas un vaccin
ça va prendre un peu plus de teint pas
compte du secteur ces deux boules
pharmaceutique le secteur technologie le
secteur alimentaire on retrouve un
niveau d'activité économique qui va et
cd celui de la voici donc certains
secteurs sargos riendeau zitter ça soit
plus de ce qu'ils mangent gignac
économique merci beaucoup au brésil à
son chien au revoir